sova mia got Ava so vom meere potential
subha Mia corteza it's the third oath of
office for Angela miracle in 2005 as the
first woman the first Chancellor from
the former East Germany and with the
first grand coalition in more than 30
years and then 2009 re-election
confirmed that Chancellor Merkel was
more than just a flash in the pan
by now Angela Merkel's third
inauguration seems almost routine what
has changed though is the rest of the
cast the people congratulating her and
of course her cabinet that can get a bit
confusing when the Federal Minister of
economics and energy I think that's
right or is it Federal Energy and
economics Minister I still need a bit of
practice but there's little time to
practice it took nearly three months for
the Christian Democrats and the Social
Democrats to solidify the coalition
though they have a huge majority their
official goals seem rather nebulous
Nicole's equality on the grand coalition
is a coalition that can handle important
issues and together we want to make sure
that in 2017 people in Germany will be
doing even better than they are today
that's why it's a fin de that's our
grand coalition agreement will also take
care of ordinary people dig of ordnance
vinh vo developer if we implement the
policies we've agreed on chances are
good that the next year's will be good
ones for Germany go to yahoo fodor
chandra the coalition agreement does
include many pet projects for both the
Conservatives and Social Democrats a
nationwide minimum wage higher pensions
for mothers billions of euros for
infrastructure in education debt
reduction and all that without raising
taxes the estimated cost is about twenty
three billion euros the financing is
still a bit murky as the opposition
likes to point out the hope they say
we're having this wonderful economic
expansion and that means more tax money
will come in and that's where the 23
billion euros will come from but what if
the economy slows down those are big
promises will they just say too bad
about our agreement it's not going to
happen hey dolls damn snow zoolander
soon to show they're ready to roll up
their sleeves the first cabinet meeting
takes place that same day
with criticism on all fronts the
government knows it needs to prove
itself opinion polls show that the
business community believes the new
government will be too generous with
social benefits that's insulting at the
diva those are things that industry
tends to look at with skepticism where
they say it's going to be a major burden
that still India hadiza and most are
convinced that the minimum wage will
also cost us jobs here in Germany
Ashland 42 coalition delegates didn't
give the nod to miracle with 462 yes
votes that shouldn't be a problem but it
also shows their skepticism within their
own ranks the conservatives especially
are worried about who will pay for the
intended programs for now though they're
mostly holding their fire at least in
public yeah our coalition agreement
promises a large number of new benefits
mainly but not exclusively in terms of
pensions everything that the state
promises in new or higher benefits also
needs solid financing behind it we need
to make sure that Germany doesn't suffer
economically or in terms of
competitiveness initiative of truck
scuffed on TV proverbs phage cut
faaliyaha Angela Merkel's third term in
office kicks off with a promise that
everyone will benefit and no one will
have to pay for it keeping that promise
won't be easy miracle knows that and so
do most Germans nearly seventy percent
expect there will be tax increases but
most of them still voted for miracle
you